I was curious if you looked at in kind
of contour distinction to the
geo-engineering a lot of the proposals
that are happening with regards to the
restoration of ecosystems to use biology
to really deal with a lot of the things
the technology isn't dealing with if
some of the things that for instance
Paul Hawkins been putting together in
his new book trawl down and I was
wondering if you had a chance to kind of
review any of the proposals around how
we kind of have we've been thinking
about climate change in an inverted kind
of way where we blame co2 but it's
actually the disruption of the
ecosystems and the capacity to stabilize
a lot of the cycles of water and carbon
that are really the issues yeah well I
think that they both are one thing it's
not just destructions of the ecological
systems are a disaster and are part of
the catastrophe that we're in the long
emergency that we're in but also burning
a fossil carbon we're not necessarily
gonna happen unless we did it so these
are two different problems and stopping
burning fossil carbon would be one thing
to do restoring ecological systems will
be another and drawing carbon down you
grow forests you go peat beds you burn
charcoal and Beria there are ways of
join carbon down and a lot of talk now
of if you could pull co2 to the
atmosphere with your if every windmill
creating electricity was using the tenth
of that electricity to suck co2 out of
the atmosphere through chemical means
you might have then a whole more dry ice
than we need you'd have to burry that
that's bad news but you could use the
carbon in carbon dioxide to make
graphene and in you could use graphene
to replace cement and cement is a huge
creator of carbon burn so that there are
some circular loops to carbon draw down
and really the tech is not the problem
this is why last year's talk was about
economics rather than tech because we've
got clean Tech's we just can't afford to
pay ourselves to put them in place fast
enough because we're trying to make a
profit on everything and so this the
economic system that we're in if you
take the iPad formula our impact equals
population times appetite times
technology the real dangerous one and I
said this to Paul err like it's not
appetite although you could call it that
it's the economic system that you're in
it's really
the capitalist system of profit and
shareholder value as the only two values
that are killing us
[Music]